they just don't lock in defensively and  this is obvious even if a tree falls in  the forest and all the other trees  laughs can any tree be trusted when  Shaquille O'Neal fell the internet broke  but Shaq wasn't LOL  a lot of people who knows I set up I say  hell yeah was it too professional  the obvious suspect nothing Charles  wants me to get hurt those Charles  always say you thought you got to kill  yourself on a set or the jet Kenny  hesitates he does hesitate he looks up  at the monitor for a second and then he  glances over so it must have been Kenya  that the job detective he had to meet a  little bit of studio a bit early that's  why I just wouldn't tell me so it wasn't  an accident  no it was  suffering humiliation  betrayal yes America I was set up but  don't worry I'll be back